ce que j'espère positif sur l'action qui
aurait l anoci la parole est à monsieur
bernard neiges
madame la ministre l'éducation nationale
je veux vous alerter sur ce qui est un
grave recul de la laïcité
le collectif contre l'islamophobie en
france vient en effet d'imposer à l'une
des écoles primaires de la commune
châteaurenard mais ça ne doit pas être
la seule la présence de mamans voilées
pour accompagner les enfants lors des
sorties pédagogiques ou non au travers
d'une note triomphante
ces mamans voilées explique grâce à
cette association
l'inspection d'académie a levé la
discrimination dont elles étaient
victimes et célèbres comme une grande
victoire ce que j'appelle moi
l'intrusion du religieux dans les écoles
de la république madame la mise
l'école de la république doit non
seulement être le premier rempart pour
défendre laïcité mais elle doit en faire
la promotion
en apprenant notre jeunesse ces
principes et ces valeurs dont vous devez
madame la ministre le car a aujourd'hui
accepté des mamans voilées comme
accompagnant des sorties scolaires
demain dans l'enceinte des écoles c'est
ouvrir une brèche dans laquelle peut
s'engouffrer toute forme insidieuse de
radicalisme religieux
enfin à quelques tricks à quel titre
la stricte application la laïcité dans
nos écoles peut-elle heurté ce collectif
contre l'islamophobie en clair s de
l'islamophobie que de faire respecter la
laïcité 6 et leurs convictions c'est
très grave et je demande une enquête
pour savoir ce qui se cache derrière ce
genre d'association madame la ministre
nous avons un héritage la france de
voltaire et de jules ferry
je demande la stricte application de la
loi de séparation de l'église et l'état
de 1905
elle renvoie le religieux dans le plus
grand respect mais avec une égale
fermeté dans la sphère privée et non
publique et l'islam ne peut s'émanciper
de ce principe constitutionnel s'il faut
un décret pour appliquer la loi en
circonstance signé le madame la ministre
la laïcité
et c'est l'école de la tolérance mais
défendre la laïcité 7000 tous les ans
kacem ministre de l'éducation nationale
de l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
merci monsieur le président que le loup
se retrouve un principe essentiel est
intangible de notre république
particulièrement précieux vous l'avais
dit à l'école lieu de neutralité
religieuse et d'émancipation qui plus
est nous faisons appliquer ce principe
avec la plus grande des fermetés depuis
le début de ce quinquennat et nous avons
ajouté à la fermeté parce que nous y
sommes attachés la pédagogie c'est à
dire faire comprendre aux élèves
pourquoi il est important que la laïcité
soit respectée pour protéger chacun
d'entre eux et garantir à chacun qu'il
sera traité pareillement par l'école de
la république
oui monsieur le député ce principe nous
l'appliquons vous évoquer la question
des parents accompagnateurs de sorties
scolaires vous savez quelle est ma
position c'est exactement la même que
celle du conseil d'état qui s'est
exprimé sur ce sujet les parents
accompagnateurs de sorties scolaires ne
sont pas des agents du service public
ils ne sont donc pas soumis à la même
neutralité religieuse que les agents du
service public
en revanche en revanche lorsque par
exemple un parent fait preuve de
prosélytisme religieux alors les
responsables locaux de l'établissement
peuvent tout à fait s'opposer à sa
présence dans la sortie scolaire
cette position d' équilibre messieurs
les députés qui vous exprimait si
vivement
c'est celle qui on retrouve de façon
constante par exemple dans une
circulaire signée en 2004 par monsieur
françois fillon alors ministre de
l'éducation nationale
tiens donc c'est une position précieuse
qui nous permet de nous assurer que les
parents s'investissent dans la scolarité
de leurs enfants ce qui est gage de
réussite de leurs enfants
s'agissant de châteaurenard monsieur le
député
l'inspectrice de l'éducation nationale
est en effet intervenue une réunion en
conseil d'école va se tenir pour que la
directrice d'école et les parents
puissent avoir les règles telles
qu'elles s'appliquent au niveau national
et donc dans cette école aussi vous le
voyez dans le
dialogue et la sérénité les choses
s'arrangent il n'y a donc pas besoin d'
attiser les braises ni d'envenimer le
débat je vous remercie